i'm much more interested in
leveraging technology to
get people out into the world
um out of their room off their couch
connecting with one another and enjoying
all the beauty that this world has to
offer and helping them learn as they go
through the exploration process
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret court ventures j ventures
riverside fm fusion vc
birthright excel
j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today we are with jason leblanc
he has been the owner of bonsai media
for more than 13 years and is the
founder of augmented reality startup
social bee which focuses on providing
tours and scavenger hunts in the real
world using augmented reality
[Applause]
you know the world is changing um
you know with your experience in the
media space and now with you know
augmented reality and all these
different technologies things are
things are rapidly changing and i'm
excited to sort of unravel your own
journey in the space and your
understandings and key takeaways so
you know we'll get right started and i'm
really you know tell me take me back a
little bit to sort of who you are and
where your interests lie because it
sounds like you're intersecting a bunch
of different things and i'm curious to
hear how though how they are sort of
coming in from different directions
yeah absolutely um
[Music]
you know i um i grew up in my my
father's business he owned a call center
and answering service and you know i did
everything from taking out the trash
every sunday and wednesday to uh to
answering the phones
and so i i in a lot of ways i became
really interested in business and so
um when i graduated college uh i always
had this idea that i would start my own
thing
um
[Music]
and then you know a few years after uh
working for a few telecommunications
companies uh
decided to uh start my own agency
um that's bonsai media group we build
websites we build apps for other
companies
and you know i was always the kid who
you know i took apart my mom's toaster
the you know the uh
any electronics she had in the house and
i really just wanted to know how things
worked
you know and so i remember taking in
college for instance my first you know
computer science 101 and i did a teenage
mutant ninja turtles website it was
uh kind of funny to to reflect back on
but
um you know i didn't go to college with
the idea that i was going to get into
computer science it was really after
that and then i was like oh wow how do
all these things work
um so i think i have kind of an
engineering mind
so as you know things progress and the
agency builds we're doing these social
contests for companies where
you know people will check in at a
location it'll unlock a trivia challenge
a video challenge
and
we got this awesome feedback people are
telling us it's such a cool adventure
it's such a fun experience
and then meanwhile i'm you know what
started as working for a
a client doing some of their their 3d
product imaging company
and learning a lot about the 3d product
space and then becoming a board member
um that i started to take this idea of
blending our
digital and physical worlds and how cool
it would be if we could
uh make exploring the world as fun as
playing video games and so i think you
know i've been really blessed in my
career and that um yeah i've certainly
put in the work and and uh and earned it
but
you know i've been able to
um
to see opportunities and see
technologies
and then uh you know have the bandwidth
to be able to pursue
some proof of concepts and turn those
proof of concepts into
uh experiences that i can sell to
clients or stand-alone products so it's
it's been a really cool journey uh
definitely a wild one i can tell you
that for sure but um the all-in-all good
and why social me
yeah great question so um
i'm not into bumblebees in fact i'm
actually allergic uh to bees but um you
know i just when i was
the idea was
really
marinating in my brain
yeah i like to talk to my friends and
say hey like i've got this idea and i
just kept on saying i want to use
technology to help people actually be
social i think at the time it was when i
first kind of concepted the idea we were
really seeing technology make people
anti-social
and i think we're
we're at a
at a point with technology where
um
you know right now or the paradigm of a
phone screen you know requires that
we're we're kind of blinders to the
world around us and i think that's what
gets me so excited about augmented
reality is it it really takes the
opportunity to raise our heads keep our
our eyes out you know connect with
people um while still interfacing with
technology
um and so really yeah the whole concept
behind socialb was to
use technology to help people be
social
so
and how does it so how does this social
aspect play into sort of this
you know
travel and under understanding the world
around and how does this all connect
back to bonsai
yeah great question so um
i think the key thing is context um
you know i spent so much time
uh just
watching people go through aquariums
museums really studying the their human
behaviors and i saw that
a lot of people go through life in a
fairly passive
um
passive way and i think
the
real uh
inspiration or the real like aha or like
what really gets you into an experience
is when
you're kind of sucked in without even
knowing you're you're learning all these
facts that kind of
tantalize your brain and just
um make that experience that much more
meaningful and rich
and so you know that that was one thing
for me was context to be able to
display information that's relevant to
what it is you're actually looking at
um you know a lot of the social aspects
is getting people to get together to go
do you know these experiences whether it
be a self-guided tour or a scavenger
hunt but then to also gamify it you know
i think part of human nature there is a
competitive
underlying current to our our spirit and
i think uh giving people something to
compete whether it's a board game or in
this case uh exploring a museum or or a
hike um can really elicit that
um that kind of fun
you know like you're a 12 year old kid
you know playing with a neighborhood
friend right and that's really what i
what i aim to do with social being and
we're just at the very very very start
of things and you know where i want to
take the technology i mean you can
imagine a networking event which can
sometimes be a little dull um but where
we gamify it and where you know and
you're wearing glasses not a phone but
uh where people have and you know an
indicator above their head where you can
learn and interact and there's some
icebreakers and things like that so i
think there's this whole world coming um
and
um so
you know as it relates
uh
to bonsai
you know
it's it's i've always looked at bonsai
as it's this it's an agency but it's
really a machine
and we can throw raw materials in on one
side and out the other comes a product
that can be
sold and marketed online and so
you know a lot of times for agencies we
need to
create capabilities in order to sell new
business lines to clients
and
it's uh it's a lot easier to sell a
client on a on an idea if you have
something that works
um you know it's it's especially in this
augmented reality vr world is so
foreign to most
business decision makers
um that they really need to see it to
believe it and so
you know i've um social b is you know by
all means it's its own entity that i um
am
fully working towards uh mass adoption
but uh at the same time it's also a
great tool for my agency whether it's to
engage in
you know um you know the the taco time
ultimate fan challenge around the the
washington state area
or to pitch different destination
marketing organizations or like we did
with uh super boats we showed them
how we can place these markers around a
boat um that was enough to solidify the
idea to them
and just were able to go build a custom
augmented reality app vr interesting
where
you can tour
build and buy
a you know competition wake boat um so
really really fun project um so
yeah it's it's a
keeping everything separated in my brain
is is a little bit hard at times but um
but the reality is is they all work
together
i mean it really sounds like you truly
enjoy the process of the creation sort
of the creative side of
you know the how these new experiences
are changing the way that we perceive
you know whatever is in front of us or
whatever we are aiming to perceive in
our mind
you're providing sort of this additional
layer and you get excited by the in the
creation of it which is really
non-trivial right
absolutely i um i spent the
my college years i was a dj
um and so
you know i looked at a lot of what i did
it was to create an experience for
people
um you know
whether that was a 80s night and you
know playing 80s movies and having
regular nintendo set up around and and
really trying to get people into this
experience and so
you know i think um
if you're into that kind of stuff then
creating the you know what could be
digital equivalents or even if it's just
a website you know there's
um there are ways to do things um to
create and to be creative you know we
don't have to do the standard you know
header hero
two column layout for every website we
build um
i think uh i i call a lot of what we do
is it's um commercial art
um so it's art for the purpose of
commercial you know um
and so it's
i try to stay true to that you can't
always do that on every project but um
it's there if you seek it
what did you learn about the way people
are experiencing
this new art and
these new experiences through augmented
reality what are some surprising maybe
even consumer behavior shifts that
you're observing that you learned from
that you're now understanding are going
to be more relevant as this is becoming
a bigger part of our of our life
yeah i think
there have been so many things i mean
everything from storytelling
uh you know at our core as humans
storytelling has been you know passed
down from generation to generations for
thousands of years right and so
um
now the tools that we have to tell a
story are becoming more immersive and
more engaging than ever before
um which i think when we harness those
technologies it makes our job as
storytellers even easier
um i've got friends who
man they can tell you the the wildest
stories and have you engaged i'm not
that guy you know i i really need um
you know the tech technology and the
elements uh to be able to pull that
story together and obviously to be able
to lean on you know uh writers and and
uh brand strategists who are much
smarter than i am in that regard so
um
yeah i think that answers your question
or
it also sounds like what you were
talking about before i mean you're
talking a lot about the things you
really enjoy about this and
you know a lot of people immediately
they go to how do these things scale the
group the fastest the greatest and yeah
here you're talking about you know
talking about a lot of purpose a lot of
about the products that that you're
really in love with
how did you discover for yourself what
you're excited about and
sort of train staying true to that and
being able to build those bridges
to to accommodate for a lot of these
things that at the end complete you
yeah
man that's
it's such a powerful thing for
entrepreneurs because i think
so often in our journey we're told
it's a dumb idea in some form of another
maybe not that directly or we're not
we're not good enough or
we may even have those own thoughts you
know about ourselves and
i think when you have a vision
um really solidifying that vision in
your brain for
what it is you want to accomplish and
then you'll feel it you know through the
process it's undeniable you get that
that you know giddy kid-like feeling
um as you're seeing these things come to
life um almost take form and and and
shape
um and then what makes it even better
and i take this back to my dj days is
you know being able to watch other
people enjoy
the things that you've created your
creation um
yeah exactly and it's um
it's really satisfying it's gratifying
and um
but it's um i think there has to be a
conviction and there has to be a purpose
because the journey is much longer than
you anticipate and it is uh much
much more tumultuous than you originally
think and if you aren't
if you don't have that purpose and that
conviction and that joy
in your work
um then
i i i would think it would be very hard
to succeed
what was it about sort of augmented
reality that got you
how do you have that conviction
you know you're looking at a bunch of
different opportunities you're exploring
a lot of different
you know interactions between people and
technology but something about this made
you say i'm going to double down on this
this is
this is good timing this is the right
thing for me
what was it a specific event or
great understanding
a few of them so i think working with
the 3d product imaging company and
seeing the
um you know increase in conversion rates
and the
you know decrease in return rates and
you know all those things are great um
but i think really for me i
um i was on the earlier side of of
gaming consoles
um i had a younger brother who was uh 10
years younger than me he got very into
gaming and i think
um
you know that world is it definitely has
its merits um but i i it's not my goal
isn't for kids to be locked in the room
my goal is for and so really what i saw
was the ability to leverage a technology
to create a better tomorrow for my kids
i have a two and a half and a seven
month old two boys
and um you know when i think of you know
things like ready player one if you saw
that movie um
spielberg movie where they're you know
they're in these vr
uh experiences and i again i think that
has its purpose
but i would
i'm much more interested in
leveraging technology to
get people out into the world
out of their room off their couch
connecting with one another and enjoying
all the beauty that this world has to
offer and
helping them learn as they go through
the exploration process so that
you know the um
you know the meaningfulness of
this peak or this trail
just resonates more with them so
that for me was with augmented reality i
saw the potential uh for a better better
future
incredible jason i
i i love the journey and sort of the
intentionality behind it sounds very
very cool i'm excited to try some of
these experiences myself one day and i
just hope that you continue having as
much fun as you're sharing here because
it's uh it's a contagious so thank you
very very much for taking the time to be
here i really appreciate it
and
best of luck with both bonsai and with
social b and all the other endeavors
that i'm sure are going to come as well
so thank you very very much for being
here
absolutely thank you michael for letting
me uh tell a bit of my story here
i love it
[Music]
you